[Musique]
salut tout le monde ça démarre mal
je viens pour parler des problèmes
communicationnel des personnes autistes
il vous faut jouer du bon soir et vous
ne répondez pas normalement c'est vous
qui est sûr c'est que notre écoute
sociaux je vais malines mais ma présence
sur cette scène est le fruit d'un
malentendu comme se voir avec moi je
comprends tout de travers quand les
personnes des organisateurs du tedx sont
venus à moi il ya quelques mois pour me
proposer de participer à la renaissance
du tedx île de nantes
j'ai été transporté ça faisait un moment
que j'attendais ce rendez vous à ce
moment là ce que je n'avais pas compris
c'est que on venait de me proposer de
monter sur la scène je pensais que je
serai parmi vous dans le public et que
j'aurai juste à me contenter d'écouter
finalement des speakers inspirant
partager un petit bout de leur vie alors
la première des plus grandes peurs de
l'homme c'est de mourir est la deuxième
des plus grandes peurs de l'homme
je suis en train d'explorer en ce moment
même c'est prend la parole en public
avant dans ma vie d'avant avant la
renaissance
j'étais responsable communication
dans une dans un grand groupe à paris là
encore un petit peu par inadvertance
parce que j'ai pas de formation
particulière
j'ai pas le diplôme significatif je n'ai
rien fait de mémorables général avec la
plupart des speakers je me suis 20 pour
moi élite et il est absolument
impossible qu'on puisse me présenter
comme une personne inspirante
imaginez un peu toute ma vie pendant
toute ma scolarité j'ai été considéré
comme un cancre 2,75 de moyenne en maths
ça ne s'invente pas mon prof de maths me
disait souvent béatrice n'essayez pas de
comprendre la logique
contentez vous de respecter la règle mes
parents quant à eux quand j'étais gamine
ne sais c'est de me dire si les petits
cochons ne le mangent pas avant on
arrivera peut-être à faire quelque chose
de toi ou encore vous connaissez tous
d'expression tu comprends vite mais il
faut expliquer longtemps vous la
connaissez tous moi cette expression
elle s'était transformée pour l'occasion
pour quelques heures le plus proche de
la réalité et ça s'est transformé en tu
comprends pas vite mais il faut
expliquer longtemps
bon les profs semblé leur donner raison
très honnêtement pas de diplôme
significative en poche j'ai cumulé les
petits boulots l'émission aussi pour une
personne qui ne comprend pas grand chose
j'étais à la fois j'ai travaillé dans la
qualité dans la formation de la
communication l'animation de comités
éditoriaux j'ai travaillé également bas
j'ai été amené à organiser et à animer
une quarantaine d'événements parents et
aujourd'hui face à vous je vais pas vous
mentir j'ai chaud j'ai l'impression que
mes joues sont aussi rouge d'un
gyrophare mon coeur bat la chamade
clairement je me sens pas du tout à ma
place je me suis longtemps demandé ce
que j'allais bien pouvoir apporter à
vous tous
comment je pouvais me montrer inspirante
sachant que j'ai pas de réalisations
simulia tiff à mon actif et tout à coup
j'ai compris qu'est ce qu'on attendait
de moi c'était d'arrêter de jouer le
rôle que j'ai joué toute ma vie toute ma
vie je me suis sûr adapté j'ai
surcompensé j'essayais de ressembler au
modèle auquel on m'impose est de
ressembler on levait tous en réalité une
personne qui était dans le déni n'a pas
là dessus de lucidité pour comprendre
qu'elle est dans le déni
un jour sur linkedin j'ai dit à monsieur
nous sommes tous conditionnés à être ce
que nous sommes
il m'a dit je peux pas vous laisser dire
ça alors j'ai expliqué comment je
percevais le monde
à l'école avant l'école même les parents
nous aiment tellement fort qu'il essaye
de nous préparer au mieux pour l'école
alors ils nous apprennent à communiquer
avec les autres donc ça donne ne dit pas
ce que tu penses par exemple dans une
dans une salle d'attenté vous avez tous
entendu un gamin dire oh les grosses la
dame a menti pas il est interdit de dire
ce qu'on pense
c'est blessant ou encore à l'école on
dit aussi ne ment pas ce n'est pas beau
alors on n'a pas le droit de dire ce
qu'on pense
on n'a pas le droit de mentir au fond
quelle chance cela laisse-t-il pour
communiquer vraiment j'ai commencé à me
demander si mes désordre
communicationnel ne venait pas de là et
un jour c'est mon fils qui m'a donné la
réponse nous avions rendez vous chez un
psy pour essayer de comprendre s'il
était autiste il devait passer toute une
série de tests
la première des questions de ce test
c'était gabriel peux tu m'expliquer
comment se brosse les dents le matin
s'il te plaît gabriel n'a pas répondu
j'ai l'impression que tout comme moi il
comprenait pas grand chose du coup la
psy lui a reposé la question une seconde
fois gabriel et c'est un peu agacé peux
tu m'expliquer comment ce bracelet dans
le matin gabriel n'a pas plus répandues
l'abc a reposé la question une troisième
fois mais là elle commence à s'agacer
parce que elle lui a dit mais si tu ne
réponds pas la question ne pourra jamais
savoir si tu es otis tu sais il ya plein
de questions car il faut au moins que
répond la première gabriel peux-tu me
donc peu dire comment tu te brosse les
dents le matin que peux tu m'expliquer
comment se brosse les dents
gabriel n'a pas plus répandues en
sortant du cabinet de jeu ap si on
arrive à la voiture
je lui ai dit tu as pas compris la
question tu avais pas envie de répondre
qu'il s'est passé il me dit maman sa
question était débile je peux quand même
pas lui dire que sa question était
débile mais la réalité c'est que quel
intérêt pour savoir si je suis autiste
de me demander comment on se brosse les
dents en plus à pas me faire croire qu'à
son âge je sais pas se brosser les dents
quand même et puis qui a entendu le ton
infantilisant qu'elle a pris pour me
poser la question elle m'a parlé comme
si je comprenais rien comme voilà et
puis tous les grimaces et les mimiques
et la fête et ils concluent pas en
arrivant à la maison
j'irai sur youtube pour apprendre à être
ventriloque comme ça je pourrais dire
aux gens tout ce que je pense mais sans
les blesser alors moi même je n'ai pas
réussi à avoir une formation de
ventriloque accéléré mais la réalité
c'est que pourquoi je me sens pas
mauvaise parce que depuis que j'ai
compris que j'étais autiste je me suis
tellement respecté j'ai tellement appris
à respecter ma véritable nature que je
ne me force plus à l'est dans les
situations sociales toutes ces choses
qui me font un petit peu de mal en fait
je voulais vous parler de communication
parce que pour une personne autiste
communiqué ce n'est pas uniquement par
les la communication du latin comme
unique a partagé m enclos main c'est
plutôt pour les personnes autistes bah
y'a pas que le fait de parler il ya
aussi bas tout l'environnement d'abord
qu'il faut exclure avant de prétendre
pouvoir entrer en communication et pour
vous permettre de comprendre un petit
peu mieux mes perceptions autistique la
façon dont je capte le monde qui
m'entoure je vous inviter à regarder une
vidéo
[Musique]
voilà là vous venez de voir un extrait
des perceptions autistique
alors je dois bien le dire pour moi les
perceptions sont beaucoup plus amplifier
encore à ce jour s'est passé comme si je
n'arrivais même plus à sortir de chez
moi tellement je le subit de plein fouet
cet environnement que j'ai appris en
fait à éviter dans le respect de ma
véritable nature
et là je dois dire que c'est un enfant
il a beaucoup plus de mal les enfants
autistes ont beaucoup plus de mal à
dissimuler
en fait les réactions que ça génère le
mal être ça génère moi la réalité c'est
que je me sens comme lui l'a les spots
les mouvements de la salle la chaleur
dans le stress bien sûr le trac mais il
ya absolument tout ce qui agit sur une
crypte comme de la kryptonite à gérer
sur superman ce soit pour moi donc il
est extrêmement difficile de prétendre
pouvoir délivrer un message quand on
subit de manière aussi amplifier
l'environnement
malgré tout je trouve que c'est
important pourquoi j'ai pourquoi j'ai
voulu parler de communication parce que
on dit des personnes autistes qu'elles
ne savent pas communiquer qu'elles sont
dénuées d'empathie qu'elles vivent
enfermés dans leur monde et moi j'ai
envie de vous dire en temple personnes
autistes
moi je trouve que c'est les personnes
dans les normes qui ne savent pas
communiquer qui vivent enfermées dans
leur monde et qui sont des lieux et
d'empathie
parce que
être sacrément dénué d'empathie soi-même
pour dire que les personnes autistes
sont dénué d'empathie
sybille ma coach que je tiens à mettre à
l'honneur me disait encore hier
ça risque d'être blessant en fait de
dire aux personnes que tu trouves que
c'est elle qui savent pas communiquer je
lui ai dit ceci si bill la plupart des
personnes dans les normes ne se soucie
pas de savoir ce qu'elles générent nous
quand alice de nous qu'on ne comprend
pas grand chose aux codes sociaux par
exemple ou quand elles disent de nous
qu'on est dénué d'empathie ou qu'on ne
sait pas communiquer je pense va je sais
que j'ai des difficultés
communicationnel mais je pense que je
suis suffisamment clair aujourd'hui le
partage le message que j'aimerais
partager avec vous c'est au delà des
différences au delà des difficultés nous
avons tous des limites et des aptitudes
différentes au delà de toutes nos
différences
ce que je trouverais intéressant c'est
qu'on apprenne à communiquer vraiment
ensemble pas se juger pas se pointer du
doigt passeriez pas su gérer cette
personne calling de cette façon donc on
va l'aider à s'adapter à notre modèle
communicationnel aujourd'hui c'est ce
que les psys fonds au niveau de
l'autisme
ils aident ils prétendent pouvoir aider
les personnes autistes à communiquer
mais nous avons une nature différente
imaginez un peu un âne et un cheval font
tous partis tous les deux partie de la
famille des équidés pourtant ne dirais
pas d'un âne toi tu es la version
handicapés du cheval non ils ont tous
les deux une nature différente
les personnes autistes comme les
personnes autistes
nous faisons tous partie de l'espèce
humaine
aujourd'hui plus de 90% des personnes
des adultes autistes sont exclus du
milieu ordinaire à votre charge
donc c'est vous qui payez pour cette
exclusion et vous payez également pour
l'inclusion des personnes autistes
quant aux enfants autistes eux ils sont
exclus du système ordinaire à plus de
80%
il n'y a que 20 % des élèves autistes là
encore les futurs petits chômeurs de
demain
je pense qu'il serait vraiment
intéressant qu'on apprenne à faire
évoluer la société au regard de la
réalité des membres qui la composent
les personnes autistes comme les
personnes dans les normes ont toute leur
place et je pense même que les personnes
hors normes peuvent apporter une réelle
différence au sein de cette société
est ce que nous avons tous en commun au
delà du fait que nous soyons tous
différents une faille ont tous uniques
c'est la planète et je pense que rien
que pour ça nous devrions apprendre à
communiquer plutôt que de pointer du
doigt les différences parce que les
personnes autistes existe réellement les
nier leur demandait de s'adapter à
modèle normalisant n'est pas à mon sens
la solution la plus inclusive
voilà je remercie
[Musique]